on les écologistes n'ont visiblement pas
besoin de leurs adversaires pour se
caricaturer ils sont véritable
caricature et simplement je constate à
quel point cette démarche vouloir punir
en permanence les français de vouloir
considérer que tout ce qui est populaire
est forcément mauvais est advenu tout à
fait insupportable
je pense que l'environnement la défense
de l'environnement mérite mieux que ces
écologistes
obsédé sur des bricoles parce qu'au fond
cette question du sapin c'est une
bricole
c'est une bricole du point de vue
environnemental mais en revanche ça ne
l'est pas du point de vue symbolique de
cette volonté de ne pas permettre aux
français y compris les plus modestes de
pouvoir se retrouver pour des moments de
convivialité avec des écologistes
politiques ont une vision de punition de
la société considère que les êtres
humains doivent être punis pour des
fautes qu'ils auraient commises et donc
cette décision là comme la question du
tour de france c'est une manière au
fonds de fonds était toujours les mêmes
français ce qui souvent les moins de
moyens les catégories les plus
populaires et de démontrer qu'il ne faut
surtout pas laisser la défense de leur
égarement à ces intégristes écologistes
la défense de l'environnement est un
combat essentiel de notre époque et je
pense que dans une période politique
nous perdons le sens des choses
nous avons besoin d'une nouvelle épopée
de nouveaux combats d'une nouvelle
bataille humaine et je pense que cette
bataille positive portée par l'humanité
celle écolo sauf que les énergies à
droite et ruban bleu est bien nous
l'avons nous avons oublié que c'est ceux
qui ont été les plus grands combattants
pour la défense de l'environnement si la
droite républicaine
concrètement aujourd'hui georges
pompidou c'est georges pompidou pardon
de le rappeler avec la création du
premier ministère de l'environnement
c'est jacques chirac avec le discours de
johannesbourg c'est le grenelle de
l'environnement bien je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que la droite doit
reconquérir ce moment là des femmes en
environnement
nous allons y travailler je vais dès la
semaine prochaine entamé un tour de
france de l'environnement j'irai partout
dans les départements de notre pays pour
voir ce qui fonctionne en termes
d'innovation en terme de conquête et de
justice au nom du parti des républicains
au nom des républicains mais ce sera
d'écologique d'achat sous l'écologie des
éoliennes si nous pouvions cessé d'être
binaire je crois vraiment que la défense
de l'environnement mérite autre chose
que ce sectarisme
je pense que c'est une formidable
aventure pour l'humanité et pour la
droite source d'innovation source
d'emplois source de jus dans la droite
ainsi et pour la droite à laquelle je
crois aussi emmanuel macron à fracturer
la société comme jamais tout cela ça ma
folle tout ça ça m'inquiète
s'il n'y a pas de noix position il n'est
pas de droite c'est une certitude mais
je vais aller au delà
vision de la société qui est la sienne
que je constate depuis trois ans à
l'assemblée nationale que je juge qui
est une vision méprisante et arrogante
qui ne laisse pas de place aux plus
jeunes qui est une vision mondialiste
font une vision fataliste
emmanuel macron il ne veut pas changer
les choses ils pensent qu'on doit se
soumettre à tout ce qui nous tombe
dessus
y compris ce fait de la mondialisation
il n'a qu'une volonté de comédie tout
cela ne correspond pas à l'idée que je
me fais de la politique et de l'avenir
de mon pays
voilà pourquoi je ne soutiens pas c'est
pas un réflexe sectaire c'est ce sont
simplement des convictions alors ça
compte les conditions